Hi I'm Nate Dern I'm the head
of the Comedy Central
Creater's program.
And I'm Ryan.
I was going to introduce. I was
going to introduce.
The Creators program
is putting five emerging
comedians together
to create a topical show
talking about everything
that's happening
in pop culture Monday
through Thursday
and that's going to be
lots of screaming
no matter what
the format ends up being.
>> And we're also going to make
a workplace comedy series.
We wake up. We think of goofy
stuff. They film it. We get
paid.
Can't argue with that.
What scale are you grading on?
Leonardo DiCaprio is a six.
Are you kidding me?
He's an 8 on a bad day.
What numbers are we? [Talking
over eachtoher]
>> What was your
first impression of Ryan?
Yeah. I thought he was a dick.
>> I know that she thought
I was a dick.
When we first met each other
and so now my first impression
has been I should always be
extra nice to Hannah.
All right. Which ones cutest
and which one would you (BLEEP)?
That's the same dog.
Yeah.
>> Trick question.
He's cool I like Jordan.
He seems like a weirdo
but I think he like is
more normal than what he wears.
>> I just found this Sub Reddit
called watch people die
which is like just found footage
of a lot of people like dying.
That sounds horrible.
Yeah it's really bad.
>> My first impression of Hannah
is she deserves to be on Raya.
If you're aware but Raya's
a very selective dating site
that has denied Hannah and I
have taken on the charge
to make sure
that she gets on Raya.
>> Yeah I need to be on Raya.
I'm a very easy date.
Like I will do you know
like it's alright.
This is like my kissing booth.
It's funny that it says trash on
it that's truly what I am.
>> You're going to hate this
question. What comedian style
would you say you're similar to?
I don't know man. I hate
this question.
Whichever comedian hates
this question most is  probably
align with.
>> Nick Kroll is
a huge influence of mine
so I like to do this like hybrid
character and standup thing
which he does so well.
I like American celebrities.
They mostly food. Kevin Bacon.
John Hamm. Scarlett Johansen.
>>Yeah? Scarlett Johansen.
The comic they that used to
compare me
to was Cedric the Entertainer
and that's because
they say I look like him.
I can't argue with that. Hey Ced
We need to do a show together.
You could be the dad.
>> When was the last time
you were embarrassed?
I don't get embarrassed
I get apologetic.
When's the last time
you apologized?
I think I've done it several
times while sitting here.
>> I think you're right.
If I thought about
about every time I got
embarrassed.
I would never leave my house.
Last time I got embarassed was
when I got the news I was picked
to be a Digital Creator.
We did it via FaceTime.
I was siting there. I didn't
know what to do my face.
Because it's FaceTime you
couldal so see your dumb face in
the top corner.
You right here.
[Stammering] How ya doin?
I got it?
>> Thanks for answering
those questions Ryan.
I'm really looking forward to
working with you in 30 minutes
when we meet up again.
Was that earnest enough for you?
I thought that was sweet.
Internet.
I thought that was nice.